Another yet more subtle technique that you can employ as
a visual designer is the use of negative space.
Negative space is developed around and between the shapes or forms of objects.
Take, for instance, this classic example of Rubin's vase.
Are we actually looking at a vase here or
are we looking at two people face each other?
You might be more familiar with examples of negative space in company logos.
For example, FedEx hides an arrow between the capital E and the letter x.
This design reinforces the company's function as shipping service.
Other logos include the television network NBC with its peacock shown here.
And the white panda from the World Wildlife Fund.
What designs or logos have you seen that use negative space?
I'd like you to share an example in the discussion thread titled
negative spaces.
After you've posted your example, check this box to continue.